hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
over the next half an hour we'll be
seeing what's making the headlines with
the broadcaster and former mp anna subri
and the sun's political editor harry
cole so a very good evening to both of
you nice to see you
so let's take a look at what's making
the front pages and the
metro leads with the head of the uk
vaccine task force
telling sky news it's possible that
every adult in the country
may be able to vac be vaccinated against
covid19 by august or
september the eye reports that an
additional
1.7 million clinically vulnerable people
have been told they should shield for
six weeks but the aim is to give them
greater priority for the vaccine and the
guardian has that same
story as its lead the telegraph
hears lockdown won't be substantially
relaxed until the number of new virus
cases
falls below a thousand a day
the mail reveals what it says is the
government's road map out of lockdown
but says the whole process will take
until july
the mirror speaks to the loved ones of
care home residents who plead
to be allowed to see them after nearly a
year
and the financial times has a story
concerning an upturn in fortunes for the
global mining industry
so anna subri and harry cole here with
me to go through some of those headlines
and anna there's an
awful lot of covered related headlines
once again isn't there
and you've picked out the metro first of
all which actually features
an interview done by um sky news's own
sam coats
with clive dix um talking about
he's head of the vaccine task force
isn't he about the prospect
of all adults getting both their doses
earlier than expected potentially
yes it's extraordinary but on the other
hand in a way
it's not extraordinary because this is a
remarkable success
vaccine roll out there's no debate about
that
the idea that we could if all adults
could have it
both jabs remember that's both jabs by
the end of august
terrific good news but i think there are
some consequences
from all of that because i think as soon
as
we begin to see the majority of people
giving their first
jab then the pressure will grow
and grow to an extraordinary level in my
view
on the government to ease the
restrictions i just think that people
will say
you know i've had my vaccine i'm not
going to get on with my life
well yes that'll be that's interesting
it's good news it could cause
trouble yeah of course it could cause
some trouble for the government and
we'll talk about some of those pressures
on
the government over the lockdown easing
timetable in a moment but just on this
um
issue harry the clive dix obviously in
charge of this body which
identifies and buys vaccine on behalf of
the uk government
feeling optimistic about the supply
there's talk about the fact that they
took this kind of portfolio approach
they've got a number of different
options so there's
some confidence coming from him but but
clearly the the rollout is important and
people coming forward is important too
yeah uh this is a typically brilliant
interview by sam coats who's got
who's got mistakes to say the one thing
the government didn't want him to say
which is actually things are going
brilliantly
there's um there's been a new sort of a
new broom in downing street should we
say over this this year
really since it began since christmas
since the turn of the year to try and
get boris johnson to stop being so
optimistic publicly
and actually under promise and over
deliver and
uh it seems the cat has been left
slightly out of the bag here but
it does seem to be a sort of growing
feeling in whitehall that
um you know the the speed at which the
target was achieved to
to jab the most vulnerable with their
first doses was hit
very well there's whispers that actually
um the number of jabs available and the
the supply chain of
jabs will be massively increasing in
into march where we'll be able to see a
million
million a day but as anus makes a point
so
so well the government got to keep a lid
on this because the last thing they want
is they want to suddenly think
actually this is over and they can go
down to the they can carry on with their
lives as if as if nothing has gone wrong
and that could actually knock the whole
roll out um off course
anecdotedly and and who can blame them i
think that we're seeing more and more
sort of older people who
haven't seen all year really out and
about in the shops in the parks and who
can blame them
just really got to there's a really thin
line between this rollout being
you know sort of on target and and
achievable and getting those numbers
down
and everyone actually breaking down the
the the order relatively good order
we've had
over what's been a horrible 12 18 months
now of of restrictions
yeah really interesting the whole
psychology of it isn't it and anna just
uh on the subject of the rollout of the
vaccination program the guardian is
picking up the story a couple of the
papers do this as well
of the fact that more people are being
added to the list of people
being told to shield and they'll move up
that vaccine
priority list as well and it's quite
interesting how this has been
determined hasn't it different risk
factors have been taken into account
yes including i don't think i'm going to
use the word poverty anymore i've never
understood why
but the fact is is that you are
twice as likely if you live
in a poorer area to suffer the worst
symptoms
of this horrible virus than if you live
uh
in a le in a more well-off area to put
it in crude terms but it's really really
important
and to see the expansion now of that
people most at risk to include people
from
backgrounds which make them more
vulnerable i think is is again
very good very positive news and i know
it's been welcomed
by the bma who were campaigning for this
because just as we identified that
older people were more vulnerable to the
worst symptoms
going into hospital some of them dying
so it's been true that
people from certain ethnic backgrounds
have had that same difficulty
and as i say people who come from poorer
areas
also so this is good this widening 1.7
up to 2 million again that's good and i
think it goes
some of the way to to alleviating some
of the
quite right criticisms that perhaps
the group looking at it this it is an
independent committee
but they have not looked in the way that
many would have wanted them
to look at for example young adults
and children with special needs and
disabilities and that they
too now should be jab so it's a bit of a
double-edged sword isn't it really
the government's doing the nhs a
terrific job in rolling out the vaccine
but now it means that people can start
to look at it with a more critical eye
well yes and and the whole debate about
the priorities will will rumble on at
every phase
no doubt of the rollout but um i want to
take us on to the telegraph
next um harry and and you talked both of
you about
the pressures with a successful rollout
on the government to
talk about easing of restrictions and
the telegraph says lockdown to continue
until cases drop below
1 000 a day so this is the number of of
cases isn't it
harry how will that what kind of
reaction might that get
well this is something that the the
medics the scientists have been pushing
for
behind the scenes we're we're told by uh
by various sources and it's interesting
that it's a
health correspondent that has their
byline on that story and not a political
reporter i always it was a
interesting criminology where for nerds
like me when things like that happen
but if you actually look at the graph
this is this is it's a very striking
front page but actually
if you drill down into the numbers about
a thousand cases a day is where
touchwood we really hope to be by the
beginning of april and the current
trajectory that we're on if you look at
the
horrific numbers between christmas and
the new year where 80
000 people were being were being
confirmed to be
uh to having a having coronavirus with a
positive test
in one day and look where we are now in
the sort of teens
you know we you hope we would be pretty
soon into
into a thousand a day and it sort of
tallies with what we're hearing
on yes there'll be a limited uh very
limited easing of restrictions in march
march the 8th and then two weeks later
uh a little bit more we're thinking sort
of you know a couple of beers in the
park with one other person perhaps
obviously schools being first but
perhaps a little bit more outdoor
exercise
but actually april is the is the sort of
penciled in marker for when
the poor blighted crippled hospitality
industry can begin to even
think about reopening and actually you
would hope that we would be on about a
thousand cases a day by then so um
hopefully that is uh you know that is
where we'll be and a very quick thought
harry picking up on what you said about
a health correspondent reporting this do
you mean this is likely to be reflecting
what those in the scientific and the
health community
absolutely yeah no obviously the prime
minister is being very clear that he
wants this to be the last
the last lockdown so to speak you know
we're not going to do this again we're
going to go
go steady and easy until to make sure we
don't have to get back into lockdown and
the scientists have turned around and
gone
all right but you know here's the
reality of that is actually you've got
to be
below a certain level by that point or
you risk leaving the embers burning
and we lock down again sorry we we
unlock again
we have a brilliant summer and wham
we're back to where we were um you know
this time next year
and and the mirror anna also reflects
some of the pressures that the
governments
under that these stories let us visit
loved ones and they talk about
the number of people in care homes who
haven't had visitors and there is that
kind of
those those real stories that so many
people have been suffering for so long
you know that that puts extra pressure
on doesn't it
yeah the chap on the front page of the
mirror i think it's called john isn't he
john ross and he's aged 89
and the photograph which you can see
shows him a year ago with his wife and
then
his photograph today and and it is
really a telling sign of the terrible
toll that kovi's had
not just in terms of the actual illness
but its consequences by people like john
who's in a home
not being able to see his wife um and i
think the pressure will
grow as both harry and i have said the
political pressure actually i think the
pressure in the
in the country at large uh whereas the
job is rolled out for people to say you
know if you've got the jab then
goodness sakes for people like john why
shouldn't he now see his wife
and i think that the other thing to add
into all of this if i may
is in may there are going to be
elections
throughout the whole of the united
kingdom and i think boris johnson
quilting on his political hat
will want to be able to make sure that
he has got good news
april coming up to may to help him get
the bounce he'll need
in those may elections because they are
across as i say the whole of the united
kingdom so
politics will loom large in his road
roadmap which he'll unroll
next week yeah interesting so much at
play and uh yes monday's going to be
fascinating isn't it when we hear from
the prime minister
uh we're going to take a break right now
uh coming up though boris johnson
apparently wants to appoint a minister
to keep the union together but will the
scots be won over we're going to be
talking about that in just a moment
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight anna suberi and
harry cole and harry we're kicking off
this section uh with another story on
the front of the daily telegraph
pm urged to appoint cabinet minister for
union so
talk us through it feels a bit like
groundhog day this story so obviously
it's all hands on deck
uh in downing street with the new union
unit set up to try and counter the
ever sort of increasing popularity of
the snp that's causing
real worries for boris johnson you know
it would obviously
be a you know a career-ending uh
uh loss to to to be the pm that presides
over the breaking up of the union so
the dunlop report which is a report into
how that you know how the union can be
strengthened has been kicking around
whitehall for a while
it's leaked to the telegraph and it's
big reveal it's grand
suggestion is let's create a minister
for the union
now there's only one problem in this in
that we've all written this story so
many times boris johnson himself
during the tory leadership election in
2019 vowed to make himself the minister
of the union and in fact he didn't
change his title he is now
prime minister of great britain northern
ireland the minister for the civil
servant the first law of the treasury
and the minister for the union and you
know
a lot of good that seems to have done so
far so the idea of creating yet another
cabinet-level job
apparently at a at a par with the
treasury or the home office or a great
office of state
um does seem a little bit like uh
replacing the sort of uh
satire sultan indeed but uh sultan deck
chairs
um on the on the titanic i just think
they have to try a little bit harder
than this to
to turn their fortunes around north of
the border i think you should get bonus
points remembering that full title that
was quite impressive
uh anna is it a good idea to have a
minister for the union
no it's a nonsense um it's just
meaningless rubbish isn't it uh and i
noticed also the telegraph says it's
going to be
a is it a big beast a cabinet big beast
well
presumably not a member of the existing
cabinet because there
aren't any big beasts in that cabinet
it's one of the biggest problems that
we've got
you're talking about
[Laughter]
and therefore i i you could argue i
speak with some authority on this
because i do know a large number of them
uh but you know this lack of big peace
especially in the christ
crisis actually i think is is a real
problem um that has bedeviled this
government but in any event
look boris johnson is a huge problem for
the union he is
a part of the problem and the growing
rise
in in the nationalist cause in uh
in scotland so it will take more than a
minister for the union to sort out those
problems
but if there was to be anybody who
should be the minister for the union
i could see that as a very good job for
ruth davidson because she's either
just gone into the lords or she's about
to go into the launch isn't she
okay it takes more than the minister to
sort out the problems for the union i
mean
these are colossal issues and they are
not going to go away
okay they're not certainly going to go
away very quickly or easily
um harry we've only got 20 seconds but
we just want to show um
page two of the metro this is uh um the
headline is a vet sacked by navy over
his sexuality gets his medals back very
brief thought on that if you can yeah i
can i had sort of had to pinch yourself
reading the the details of the story and
seeing the reports on sky today that
this was only 25 years ago 20 years ago
in some cases this feels like something
out of a history book and shows just
you know how phenomenal the the speed of
change has been in the last two decades
but
you know one small step with medals now
uh you know
real real justice is needed with you
know with wallets and
pensions and all sorts of things like
that and i can see you nodding that anna
you agree yeah absolutely right yep
okay and we are out of time but um anna
and harry good to see you both and
you'll be back again at 11 30 to go
through another selection with us thanks
very much indeed for
now so let's take a look then what's
making the front pages and the metro
leads with the head of the uk vaccine
task force telling sky news
it's possible that every adult in the
country may be able to be
fully vaccinated against covid19 by
august or september
the eye reports that an additional 1.7
million
clinically vulnerable people have been
told they should shield for six weeks
but the aim is to give them greater
priority for the vaccine
and indeed the guardian has that same
story too
the daily telegraph hears lockdown won't
be substantially relaxed until the
number of new virus cases
falls below a thousand a day
the daily mail reveals what it says is
the government's roadmap
out of lockdown but says the whole
process will take until
july the times understands there are
plans to roll out
mass testing to people's homes in an
effort to speed up
a return to normality the mirror speaks
to the loved ones of care home residents
who plead to be allowed
to see them after nearly a year
meanwhile according to the express the
queen believes prince harry will honour
his personal loyalties
and royal protocols in an upcoming
interview with oprah winfrey
the financial times has a story
concerning an upturn in fortunes for the
global mining industry
and the star splashes on darts players
choosing
pilates over pints
anna subrey and harry cole here with me
to go through some of those
front pages and anna a lot of different
angles to the ongoing uh covid story
you've picked out the front page of the
times to kick us off um and
this is talking about uh plans they say
are afoot
for more mass testing to try and give us
more freedom
so what are the time suggesting is going
to happen
so they're speculating that in this road
map
that the prime minister is going to give
details of
next monday that one of the things that
he will announce is that there will be
400 000
lateral flow tests that will be sent to
people's homes or to their place and
work
a day i mean that's an extraordinary
number and it's as if finally the
the testing and tracing system is going
to catch up
somewhere near the success of the
vaccine because test and trace has not
been the greatest success that it should
have been
but it's an extraordinary number 400 000
a day
that means 100 000 people a day getting
tested at home or in their place of work
the concern will be that that test is
not as good as the other test which is a
laboratory test
that this test this lateral flow takes
about 30 minutes for you to get a result
but it's critical whatever your views of
the government's handling so far of the
covid crisis
that that testing and tracing
is absolutely as important as the
delivery of the vaccine if we're to
get the sort of thing that we want which
is a return somehow
to some form of normality and harry with
the head of the vaccine task force
telling sky news tonight i think it
makes one of the front pages as well
that all adults could potentially be
fully vaccinated i.e both doses by
august or september
the question then is to what degree that
gives you extra freedoms
um and this the times article suggests
that the
the government is focusing on this idea
of testing
giving you greater freedom rather than
perhaps some kind of
vaccine passport to use at home is that
how you see it
yeah we've been pushing on this you know
as a day in day out really for the last
of a couple of months really of
you know are you are the government
looking at vaccine passports if so
how they're going to work and if not why
aren't they looking at them
um and up this up their sleeve seems to
be this mass testing there's a
ocean of speculation tonight about what
could possibly be coming in the next few
months to help us out of
lockdown because this time particularly
well sourced um in terms of
the prime minister talked about this
before he back i think it was
the last time it was coming out of
lockdown back to july last year
he started talking about operation moon
shots which was this idea that you know
a taking a a covered test could become
as normal as brushing your teeth in the
morning
before you go to work and it's not
necessarily about um
you know the ability to go back go to a
football match or the theater or the
cinema again
it's actually about getting people back
into offices into workplaces
which is an underlying fear that uh that
you know
cities and towns will never ever be the
same again unless there is a dramatic
increase in the number of people
who you know lots of people got quite
used to working from home and quite like
it it's how can we get people back into
mass situations again
not necessarily leisure but actually for
for the the
for the economy so the government
quietly been spending absolutely
bucket loads of cash on this on this and
there has
rightly said being a real issue with
lateral flow tests well
because they're not as accurate as a lab
test now
someone i was bringing to the other day
said yes that is still the case
they're getting better but hand in hand
with the vaccine
actually that sort of five six seven
eight percent
you know sort of um you know sort of
error
it's a margin of error you get on some
of these cases isn't as critical
as it would have been if there hadn't
been a vaccine so actually they can
now start to be rolled out for more
everyday use
and actually the private sector has been
using these um
you know for a fair few months now to to
to privately test their workers
and it looks as if finally the
government as anna says is is catching
up and test and trace
which you know the testing capacity is
massive now
800 000 people a day we can test but the
tracing isn't there but if people can do
it in their own home before they leave
home in the morning
it will make all the difference in in
the acceptance really that covert is
going to be with us forever
it's not going to go away but you know
how we tackle it
is you know it will is you know a very
fluid very
fast-moving uh situation well yes and
the financial times though
meanwhile um anna says some employers
draft no jab no job contracts as
business left to go it alone so
even though there's these suggestions
that tests might be the way uh to free
things up
there seem to be some employers that
want to have
contracts for their staff potentially
what do you make of that
i've i find it very difficult to
understand
how you could work in a care home and
not have had the vaccination
i just find that quite extraordinary um
now it raises huge issues and no doubt
it will be a bit of a minefield for any
lawyer
but as i say i think there are certain
jobs
in fact a lot of health workers social
workers
people who are dealing with and working
remarkably with
some of the most vulnerable people to
cope with it's difficult to see how you
can do that job
and not have a vaccine for any good
reason
because you are posing a threat to them
and indeed of course to yourself
your own family and for the whole of
this project
which is effectively to build up
antibodies as
in as many people across our country and
of course we should be going
beyond right across the world as we can
if we're to get back to normality
can i just say one thing actually you do
find is quite interesting
is that in all the front pages the num
number of deaths is
tucked away as an aside 799 people died
from coving still an extraordinarily
high
number but as harry has pointed out of
course the one thing that johnson wants
to achieve
or rather he doesn't want is that third
wave
and so-called spanish flu back in 1918
had a third wave which wasn't as deadly
as the first
wave but wasn't far off the second and
he's keen rightly
to avoid that well yes and we should
remember
as you say those figures because those
are you know
all individuals with families and loved
ones aren't they and we should
uh always have those at the front of our
minds you're absolutely right
um but that that desire by the prime
minister and the whole country of course
to not have to go back into a third
lockdown presumably
affecting how he decides to come out of
this one harry and the front page of the
daily
mail um has um fact or speculation you
tell me
about um what how that might look on
monday when he and he talks about
his timetable yeah i mean this is um
with the greatest of respect to a deadly
rival uh newspaper it's uh it
is what we call it in the trade a bit of
a mosaic um
they put lots of different bits together
and and and then slapped a big headline
on it saying revealed this is this is
the plan
it's not the plan no one knows what the
plan is in fact the plan hasn't even
been signed off yet so
it's a good pun it's good uh it's good
sport and you know the government
actually left themselves slightly open
to this in the fact that they announced
that in three weeks time
three weeks ago they would announce a
plan so they feel they've
created a bit of a vacuum there which is
obviously going to be filled
uh this uh story actually seems to be
coming from less from government and
more from the hospitality trade
and it feels like they're a bit they're
a bit miffed by some of these aspects of
it because we've
you know there's this there's this
phrase in there which is
things won't be back to normal until
july
now i think that's quite ambitious and
the fact that there is
you know there is an argument that
things are never going to be
back to normal as we know it you know
they're for
for a lot of for you know for a lot of
people they're gonna come you know
get back to normal wait for that local
pub to rip and it
sadly isn't gonna reopen because it's
gone bust
you know it's it it's this idea that you
know there's gonna be a thick of a
switch and overnight things are the same
again i just don't think it's gonna be
like that um
now the the road map i think will have
some very i think it'll be quite vague
ironically for a road map i think it
will be
reliant on you know certain criteria
being met and as you said
and as anna said you know it will be at
a very very cautious pace because they
are
you know they want to have the the fact
they want to give the vaccine chance to
bed in to show that it works to prove
that it works
for any lifting of major restrictions
and you know when you look at
things like jonathan van tan the deputy
chief medical officer
has said about social distancing and
mask wearing
and you know sort of sitting outside for
the foreseeable future
you really have to do take a hefty pinch
of salt
every time you do see that phrase back
to normal because
you know the new normal is going to look
very different to the pre-pandemic world
yeah and on that rather sober note we
are going to take a break right there
but um
don't go away either of you lots to talk
about in just a moment including has the
bbc done the right thing by saying
it won't prosecute over 75 for failing
to pay
the license fee we're going to be
talking about that next and anna we're
kicking off this section with a story
inside the metro aren't we
about a gay a navy veteran in this case
but
his story repeated no doubt many times
over
the headline there vet sacked by navy
over his sexuality
wins back medals what's your response to
this as someone who's
been a defense minister
yeah i was a defense i was a defense
minister and
and i mean i'm i'm quite speechless in a
way
on two counts first of all i mean it is
extraordinary
that what 30 years less than 30 years
ago
people were thrown out of the armed
forces for no other reason
than they were gay i mean it is it is
unbelievable
but it happened uh and it meant that
when they were dishonorably discharged
it is really quite disgraceful
any medals that they had or any
recognition of service
so that gentleman in the metro is called
joe oralis i think he pronounced his
name
in any event he was a veteran of the
falklands he he served in the falklands
he did six tours of duty
in northern ireland and his his service
was just
wiped away humiliated heartbroken
left penniless mercifully now
it is that these terrible wrongs are
being right and good to see ben wallace
who's the secretary of state there
restoring what is due to him but there
is another fight now which is to make
sure that
these wonderful people all of them get
their full pension rights and their pay
restored to them uh it's i think the
very least that we can do and i just
wish that we'd done it when i was a
defense minister we had another big
issue
which was another injustice to do with
pension with widows rather than their
pension rights
but this is another huge injustice which
thank goodness has now been righted
okay yes so um and let's move on harry
to another story on the front of the
daily telegraph which has taken your
interest
uh bbc declares television license
amnesty for over 75s
yeah i believe this is uh you know
the last thing the bbc would want to do
that's probably gonna
as a great you know kind uh a kind thing
but in fact it's almost because it's
unenforceable and they were facing a
massive
massive backlash uh anna will remember
this better than i do but this all
stems back to the great sort of
austerity days of george osborne versus
versus the the giant bloated uh
government spending and he basically
the government used to pick up the tab
for um for uh for bbc
license fees for over the 75s and he in
a piece of quite depth negotiation
somehow managed to get the bbc to take
this on to their own books
and once they realized quite how
expensive that was going to be
all hell has broken loose over the
corporation and this is sort of seems to
be the inevitable
uh end game of that in a row that's been
running for as long as i can remember
as a journalist that's probably close to
10 years
10 years that's i was going to say i
think i remember it going for even
longer perhaps
anyway on that note before we get down
the alleyway of how old i am let's
wrap things up shall we anna and harry
always good to see you both thanks very
much indeed for your time tonight we
appreciate it
pleasure